everybody know already mr. Kelly was
denied bond we're not very happy about
that but that's decision of the judge so
we have to live with it we have the
options of Appeals we will do that and
as I said from very beginning to
everyone you have to bring the proof if
you don't have the book it won't cheap
and I'm really interested
well mr. Greenberg's on his way so maybe
I should wait for mr. Greenberg he told
me to go here we're gonna wait on him
okay you told me to go here but I'm
gonna wait
Oh
well obviously we're disappointed we
were hopeful that the judge would let
him out today I think that's appropriate
there's a he was talking about
presumptions and there's a presumption
that he shouldn't get bond unless we
could show that there were conditions
that were would ensure basically the
safety of the community the fact that
these allegations are decades old the
fact that he hasn't done anything
there's no clear danger presently or
anything like that we thought we'd get
him out but the judge saw it otherwise
and we respect his ruling and we'll look
at it our options for miracles
he's obviously disappointed I mean
obviously he's disappointed you know
he's in 24 hour day solitary confinement
essentially it's it's the whole because
that's the safest place for them to
house them and it's not his fault no TV
no anything no contact with other people
it's it's largely inhumane
it's never mr. right he's never he's
never missed a court date he's never
been late for a court date he doesn't
have a passport he doesn't travel
anywhere
he's absolutely not a flight risk
well I think the prosecutor said that
one of the tapes they charged was from
the old case that they've got two other
tapes I haven't seen the tapes I don't
know anything about the tapes all I
could tell you is that back when he went
to trial on the the case back in 2008
jury saw the tape jury acquitted up I've
spoken to mr. Kelly about the case many
many times the potential sentence I
don't think that's I mean what would
your reaction be right you know no one
wants to be in jail no one wants to be
in jail for a day for a year no one
wants to be told they're gonna spend 10
years or 20 years in jail so no one
wants to be in jail but he's not there's
no evidence that he ever did it you know
was very interesting the prosecutors
said that that the people previously
tampered with witnesses on his behalf
they didn't say was at his behest they
didn't say that he knew anything about
it
okay no they said that they did it on
his behalf that it was for his his
benefit and that he orchestrated there's
not going to be anything
well it says it says that the money came
from our guy our Kelly has paid hundreds
of thousands of dollars millions of
dollars over the years that he knows
nothing about nothing about he's been
robbed of everything by his handlers
I don't I don't deal with mr. abinanti
from the previous trial I haven't seen
any evidence I can't respond we can
respond to things we haven't seen any
evidence of their allegations you know
that's the one thing where the judge at
the end was talking about the grand jury
and what the grand jury grand jury found
that that there was probable cause based
on whatever they were given by the
government there wasn't been a finding
of guilty we haven't seen the evidence
we haven't analyzed the evidence we'll
start doing that as soon as they get it
to us thank you yes